natürlich man trifft sich auch ab und zu
mal mit einem mädchen macht man ja ab
und zu nah fall
und letztens ne eines video etwas klappt
uns willkommen bei der neuen video ich
habe heute wieder christian dabei und ja
wir haben uns gedacht daher so
bombastisch sensationelles wetter ist so
portmann lieber verlegen wir unser set
doch einfach mal nach draußen und die
einzig wirklich gefühlte 40 grad würde
ich mal sagen
deswegen haben also direkt investieren
dazu geholt von gerolsteiner kann ich im
empfehlen und zwar haben wir uns für
heute gemacht wir reden einfach mal
darüber dass hier eine gemütliche runde
gemacht wie gesagt schönes wässerchen
und kommen auf den punkt ich komme jetzt
auf den punkt wir wollen natürlich was
über sachen erzählt gewissen und zwar
geht es hier ist es so schön formuliert
was bei mädchen gar nicht geht
logos bei nied ich hatte das ja schon
mal gemacht aber das ist schon so ein
jahr her und da war ich selber noch voll
da bin ich immer noch
wir sind natürlich auch ein bisschen
weiter vorangeschritten und einfach mehr
erfahrungen im leben gesammelt und
deswegen gibt sollte was den mädchen gar
nicht geht das ausgelutschte thema was
es auf youtube gibt aber egal ja ich
würde mal sagen wir legen direkt los und
gefällt last auf jeden fall noch nach
oben da freut es immer sehr dann erstmal
bescheid und los geht's ja und ich würde
sagen ich fange jetzt einfach mal an und
zwar aus mich so richtig aufregt was ich
überhaupt nicht geil findet ist der
mädchen oder frauen einfach viel zu viel
arbeiten als sie eigentlich müssen zum
beispiel ich esse ich mach ab und sogar
meine hausaufgaben ab und zu auch nicht
und wenn dann da so mädchen in die
schule kommt und ihre hausaufgaben
vorliest und keine ahnung acht seiten
geschrieben hat und dann sagt ja dafür
habe ich so eine stunde brauche ich mir
10 sa locker fünf stunden ran
das für das regt mich so auf ich weiß
wie sie
aber ist ja ja ja ich weiß was du meinst
soll ich lieber so um als ich meine das
schon wichtig aber man soll sie
betreiben und das mit freundinnen machen
will hat mit den fingern boris was mir
immer noch eingefallen ist ist der punkt
das mädchen wenn sie in der gruppe sind
mit vier fünf sechs sieben acht mädchen
waren immer schön und ich so halten wenn
zum beispiel x10 und andere bolt der
baum kommt den ausgängen jetzt ein
motorrad weiter wenn man wenn ihr das
beispiel alex sehen und wird dann so
alle sechs mädchen gleichzeitig fangen
an zu kichern und so richtig laut auf
youtube video das ein bisschen also ich
find das ein bisschen nervliche top und
ja dann gehen wir wahrscheinlich direkt
zu acht leuten alle mal auf toilette und
erhalten sich da ein bisschen was sie da
machen mich manchmal wie ich das gar
nicht wissen' finden spricht mich jetzt
nicht so an aber ist jetzt nicht schlimm
wenn ihr das macht aber wie gesagt so
der nächste punkt kommt natürlich wieder
von mir und zwar ich war bis vor acht
neun stunden war ich noch feiern und
comeback am ende da waren neben mir ich
habe fünf stunden schlafen im
briefbereich du da waren neben mir so
zwei so mädchen falls das mädchen waren
sei auf jeden fall ein bisschen so aus
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine und ich
waren so voll dass ich habe noch also
ich sie ab und zu mal mädchen voll aber
die waren wirklich voll und die waren
wirklich nur zweiter in der disco ich
frag mich wie kann man sich denn zu
zweit als mädchen so besaufen und dann
haben wir die ganze zeit ihr handy
genommen haben sich damit gefilmt und so
übels getanzt und die ganze zeit sind
die nach oben gelaufen und haben andere
leute auch gefilmt mich auch nicht
da habe ich mir gedacht ja gut
das fand ich so eklig das war nicht echt
ehrlich hat fasste kurz was ich richtig
scheiße finde wenn mädchen überhaupt
nicht lustig sind nicht lustig sind oder
gar keinen spaß verstehen hast du wenn
man so ein bisschen bizarr
erst mal direkt whatsapp blockieren
alles blockieren nicht mehr mit ihm
reden wenn man ein bisschen spaß gemacht
hat guter punkt oder grüße aus santonja
alles raushauen
sie weiß wer gemeint ist so zum grünen
abschluss machen wir hier noch schnell
zusammen das letzte logo und zwar
natürlich mein trifft hier auch ab und
zu mal mit einem mädchen gemacht man
jemanden ab und zu ja falsch und
letztens eine gruppe stoppt das video
egal ob mädchen du redest mit denen die
treffen sich extra mit dir und die sind
die ganze zeit am handy ohne scheiß ich
denke so czech die das nicht dass das
hatte ich schon aber ich hoffe das stell
dir vor ich wäre ganze zeit am handy das
ist es erstens voll unhöflich zweitens
kommt da kein gespräch zustande
und ich hasse gegenüber regel stimmt ich
habe mich ich dachte mir so was ist
falsch bei dir du bist nicht einfach
nach hause fahren oder divx inc das
könnte man wirklich also eigentlich ist
voll fies wenn man so einen weg schickt
oder einfach antwort aber bei sowas
nenne ich würde das machen ohne scheiß
und dann ist sie da am handy und macht
die ganze zeit auch noch sprache notizen
zu ihren freundinnen schreibt mit ihren
freunden und so snapshot hier die ist
das denken ist wenn man in hessen jetzt
falsch was wissen wir nein spaß heute
unser ziel eingefallen aber wenn ihr
bock dass wir das noch mal machen dann
können wir natürlich noch mal bisher
mehr überlegen lassen daumen nach oben
da schreibt in die kommentare
wird uns sehr freuen ach sein instagram
so jetzt wenn ihr wenn ihr ihn süß
findet dann folgen noch instagram wollen
sie die einwände tiergruppen mich
geschlagen
ich würde mich jetzt sogar einfach so
freuen
genau die nicht vergessen überlassen wir
sind uns nächsten mittwoch eventuell
wieder ich bin ja schon jetzt wenn ihr
das video sieht in rimini nicht und dann
wird bestimmt megacool schöner in
erfahrung mariner entspannter
strandurlaub mit der family sie gehört
auch dazu
sonst würde ich sagen hier oben links
links geht weiter mit meinem metz video
das war die erste folge meines neuen
formates alex privat check das auf jeden
fall ab und hat ein hatte